In this module we're going to talk about something called convergence and a lot of people
refer to this as IP. In this module we're going to talk about something called convergence and a lot of
people refer to this as IP convergence and some people get confused as to what it means but
basically IP convergence is the ability of our data networks that we've had for a very long time to
carry not only data but a whole bunch of other things that have become really important for companies to
address across their networks today. So for example IP telephony or voice over IP the ability of the
network to not only carry data but also multimedia audio video and possibly some other things as well
is what we call convergence. When you think about what networks were built to do was only carry data but
today they've got to do much more and that's what we call convergence. Convergence is simply the
ability of your standard TCP IP network to carry data and a whole bunch more and these are some
examples. We've got fiber channel over ethernet we've got ice-cazy capabilities for doing things related to
storage and backing up and restoring and probably the most obvious example of converged protocols which
means the ability of the data network to carry also voice which a lot of people refer to as voice over
IP but more appropriately should be called IP telephony. And so when you look at the traditional way that
companies had to connect themselves to the voice network in the past for voice capabilities we had to
basically connect ourselves to two distinct networks companies would have had to connect themselves to the
voice network for voice requirements and then we built data networks to handle our data requirements.
What we can do today is we can actually carry voice over our data network and that's one example of
IP convergence because now we have technologies that can allow us to take your voice, digitize it,
packetize it and then carry it across the data network so that you and I can carry on a
conversation really across a data data network and that's what we call IP telephony or some people call
voice over IP but when you look at the way that fundamentally our data networks are done and built the way
that we carry information across networks is by taking your information breaking it up into packets and
then sending those packets across a network those packets may travel in different directions they may arrive in a
different order than they were sent so fundamentally it wouldn't be easy to allow you and I to be able to carry on a
conversation if that's the way that our voice communications was sent across a data network so that's what voice over
IP or IP telephony protocols have given us the ability to do. We can take our voice, digitize it, packetize it and send it across the
network as packets but address some of the issues that would result if those packets for example traveled in different
directions so these are some of the most popular protocols that the industry has developed to allow us to
carry voice across data networks and not have some of the problems that would be associated with that so SRTP is one that
actually adds some security into voice communications because if you think about how we can carry voice over data that would
mean that we inherit the insecurities that typically data networks have I mean if you look at a data network
fundamentally it does not address confidentiality or integrity or availability and so if you want security of your voice
transmissions natively it's not there if you're just doing IP telephony or voice over IP without using specific
protocols like this one SRTP does add the ability to have secure transmission of voice
communications by using things like authentication and encryption as part of how you and I ultimately communicate across that IP telephony network another
popular one is SIP the unfortunate part about IP telephony protocols is that there really isn't many standards in the industry
usually the vendors will standardize on their own protocols and then if you go with the specific vendor you're typically limited to the security
capabilities that that vendor will give you which might not be enough to address your requirements for authentication
encryption and some other things that might be very important in your voice communications across your entire data
network especially if you're going across different countries or around the globe and using voice over IP or IP telephony but now if you're using IP telephony
protocols which means you can carry voice over data it's very important to address some of the security concerns that that really
allows for example if you want confidentiality of those voice transmissions natively it's not there and so if you want to achieve confidentiality we need to encrypt
but the problem with cryptography and encryption is that it adds what we call latency latency means it takes time to encrypt
and it takes time to decrypt at both ends so if you want confidentiality and you encrypt the transmissions it may result
in a little bit of a delay in how you and I are communicating by using voice communications which might make it very frustrating
you've all experienced this where if you call someone up with your mobile phone and there's a bit of a delay in that transmission
it's very difficult to communicate and that would be the case every single time that we would use encryption
in voice over IP transmissions integrity is hard to achieve as well one of the easiest things that you can do
across a IP telephony environment is to pretend to be someone else or pretend to be from a number that someone else
represents and so these are easy things you just need software to be able to achieve some exploits and vulnerabilities
across your IP telephony environments and it's a reason why we see a lot of wishing type of attacks today
and you may know what this is but it's a form of fishing that specifically happens across your voice over IP
environments because it's very easy for the attackers to spoof no numbers or numbers that may look familiar to you
and that's how they get you to provide information that you shouldn't that's what we call wishing attacks
just a other flavor of fishing that uses voice over IP capabilities that every company has because they've
implemented IP telephony solutions